hey everybody welcome to today's Monday
Mellie
thank you for joining us my name is bleh
here in the chat room is Beth Moravsky
Steven Smith on the ones and twos and
creeper Jason O'Malley today we're gonna
be playing no joke when my favorite
games of all time state of decay which
if you haven't heard of it before I
think it was like at one point like the
most popular game on xbox live arcade or
something whatever and for three xbox360
I poured lots of hours in this game it's
a zombie game kind of like Grand Theft
Auto but with zombies it's very fun and
they just released it last month
it relates the year 1 survival edition
for Xbox one which is fantastic and it
includes two other games state of decay
breakdown state of decay lifeline so I
think we took a vote in here and we all
think we're gonna play state of decay
breakdown but I actually get to import
my old xbox 360 save which I'm very
excited about you get to meet all all my
favorite people including Rylan who
really got us out of Trumbull Valley
those who have plates to indicate no I'm
talking about I got us out of Trumbull
Valley blew up the wall that the army
put up around and one of the things
about this game is you're dying is
permanent so when you die that's it
your guys good guys dead forever and
before they released a patch I'm also
saying this for the people here I'm
super excited about soon before they
released a patch for the up for the Xbox
360 game it was like Animal Crossing in
that when the the console was turned off
the game was still happening so before
you had and this is why I got so
addicted this game before you had like I
would be playing till like 1:00 or 2:00
in the morning and then be like oh my
god I have to collect enough food for my
survivors while I'm at work tomorrow or
else they're gonna die while the console
is off and I would turn back on the game
and it would be like oh these people had
died it was awful but they fix that
patch that doesn't happen anymore but
it's a very fun game
good to see you Sully boy shady fridge
hello sticks n91 no Conan again if
you're just joining us for the first
time a thank you for joining us but be
sometimes Conan shows up sometimes he
doesn't depending on the shooting
schedule
so it depends lankey mongrel state of
decay was in France would be called
state of mone well played well played or
yeah okay okay
let's play state of decay breaks out oh
I guess we have to start a new game for
this should we played so we continue the
other game yeah
who choose your hero all right random
non hero character yeah
hey MF Jones 1 1 7 how's it going hello
snooze R then good to see you mate
Mattos r hello Marlin hey what you watch
all Irish good to see it nice and a lot
of thing there
how many rhymes can we come up with for
state of decay state of mone oh [ __ ] ah
Jesus right also this game is real scary
I'm just there's gonna be a lot of
scariness I also like how it takes a
long time to kill a zombie just uh if
you guys are eating or anything you're
not gonna want to eat during oh yeah no
nothing's ever easy please alright so
here we go those jeans are tight hey
Paulin what's up did you guys like the
hey who's the Polish person did you like
did you like The Witcher 3 we just did
Witcher 3 which is a Polish game Bethel
hit you with the lake in the chat
actually you know what the people the
designer designers who came to show us
Witcher 3 and brought the game over from
Poland actually brought brought me some
awesome polish I want to see like cherry
vodka or something oh yeah oh yeah scuse
me yep it's this blue shiz how you know
the zombies dead which I appreciate
Mexico hoes you do 28 2007 who did that
stay to play shady fridge
points as hardwick would say that's
pretty impressive that is impressive
I'm a little depressed stand of what and
a state of party the thing is this game
is great because you can it's an open
world game okay oh that guy definitely
need to see a chiropractor let me help
you with that buddy this is great and in
this game so you can go anywhere in this
game which is really fun yeah this is
sandbox which is great and the graphics
are way better than they were on the
Xbox 360 obviously but what I love about
it is for a lot of this game you have to
just run away like you would actually
run away in actual zombie land Oh God so
there is like a sense of like go get
that car you do want to there is a sense
of just like licious run cuz you can't
really oh my god they're chasing me
let's even get behind him and there's so
there's a lot of like sneaking around
and it's kind of like let's get this car
oh yeah let's go let's go
splooge oh I'm not terrible driver by
the way oops sorry oh yeah this is great
oh it's so easy to just destroy oh
there's a zombie on the hood of my car
get rid of this guy got him this please
somebody to show the graphics and this
are better than h1z1 h1z1 he's like
another isn't it like an MMO guys
yeah this game is super fun you guys
hiring interns my history is clean never
stolen as much as a cup mmm interesting
thing to open with yeah interesting
openers stolen any cups not cut to cup
order yes another cup that's the only
reason why he's an intern we're all the
goddamn comes in here what are the cups
going ooh
extra door attack ooh I do like that
let's do some doors that's awesome let's
do a door attack wait get these guys
over here
come on boys also in this game come on
out to the road fellows come on out I
definitely won't steal any cups or hit
you with the door attack come on come on
you guys can do it here we go the
classic boom no is I think that's a new
thing yeah oh yeah dude all right here
we go let's see what's going on here
I'll kill all those people
oh yeah wait hold on let me just get
back in the car it's way easier just
like in real life hit him with a door
Uber's here somebody called for an uber
oh this is great oh whoops all right get
in come on get in no wait if you're just
stationary can you just open the door
after that oh no no no
she's just gonna lay there yeah come on
over here we just scrape the sky off the
side of my car oh they don't put some
new doors yeah there we go
battle royale h1z1 is awesome so h1z1
whoops whoops and this is a great car no
yeah you can't you gotta wish you would
just explode all right I'm afraid of no
ghost state if souffle Leckie mongrel
somebody already said that stated
souffle
this guy's got a red eyes what's up with
that you know I need to do is run can
you get off me dude you just got bit by
me are you gonna no no I'm fine I'm fine
everyone shake it off Runaways doesn't
run away oh god oh I'm hurt no no this
is bad doesn't make it oh Jesus
I think No get up get up please get up
get in the car get back in the car let's
get back in the car I'm out of here a
lot it don't worry about a pretty
fundamental flaw with this no it's not a
flaw
I just got scraped that's a huge flaw No
you get bit by a zombie you don't become
a zombie no I don't know I think there
it's more like if you die then you
become a zombie I'm not actually sure I
don't know the zombie rules you don't
know I know the basic zombie rules but
not in the state of decay you know what
maybe it's more of a it's maybe it's
more like an inherited thing like
allergies you're like money I never
played Dead Island 2 now dying likes fun
oh they're quite a bit all right I have
to figure out let's see here do I have
here I got some ibuprofen Oh that'll do
it that'll do it I don't fix your deep
flesh how do I use this how do I just
put an ibuprofen in the wound
yeah how do I use my ibuprofen come here
dry dry dry we just back up over his
head kill the zombie on the ground or
kneeling how do I do that all right next
close gamer from Pokemon a GBA GBA game
boy advance oh I actually won I did get
a 3ds XL which I've been playing which
is fantastic can I use stuff in the car
doesn't look like did you see that one
comment about the finisher say that
again take a lot of damage or use my Mac
do that oh here we go got it got it
that's an army guy sorry sergeant brand
Brando Brando virus dilantin too quickly
you guys should understand
I actually just bought a souped-up PC
today should be coming today who lb+ why
here we go lb RAL bprous wire it's the
OC of lingerie yeah batter up
learn to fighting are you just trying go
inside yeah I'm going to
I want to sneak around I want to secret
that guy's just jamming he's yeah he's
rockin out yeah they can climb on oh
yeah that guy's gonna murder the [ __ ]
out of you no no no what fine we're fine
he's not good doing that guy Bush
completely yep I want to do that go in
the warehouse just give me a second you
got it we're gonna clear things away man
you could have killed all those dudes
just give me a second I'm gonna go hide
in the bushes okay uh what computer die
by Adele somebody knows it's the same
one we use the twitch here Tanner
furless is a-okay all right seven a core
i7 whoo yeah a flip yeah the flim-flam
hatchback xsplit situation all right
well these guys are definitely not
coming over here you know what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna go into the back here
let's go to the back state of parfait
lone-wolf
already been said is that true yeah
state of my men eject away the state a
Kansas
those are some finesse branches all
right man
oh that guy's trying to bust in there ah
you know I wonder if I could sneak up on
this dude and blob 3:52 it I think that
stands for a general processing unit
what GPU yeah graphic what do we say how
do I kill someone instantly how do I
kill someone instantly I've never looked
that one up
never gets old never gets old all right
let's sneak in here let's go in the side
and see we get some supplies some more
aspirin to help me with my zombie
infection here's the thing so searching
in this game see it's that blue circle
is you making noise so when you search
stuffing makes noise this game is super
scary especially like when you're
playing alone by yourself and I'm not
wearing any pee right oh yeah let's take
it take it off yeah I can't I think I
have to break this up
Riger 488 that's no good
I don't do this break open oh good I got
an axe do you love the old axe I don't
think I want to set up an outpost here
though do I save your Z this is why we
need to see this is why we need to clear
all the zombies because otherwise it's
very loud you should close the door
behind you it doesn't matter
well I mean it probably takes did you
just pick up all those bricks are they
disappeared for no I do want a radio
radio in I can hear somebody's in your
state of the fray you see me or state of
the phrase state of all a really just go
down what's you're getting supplies I'm
trying to radio in for supplies here
I mean ready I want a radio into
scavengers yeah can I do that yet take
yourself a pus-y to radio in for
subscribers take it for you great so can
I do that please or we're not at that
point now Aaron how bad did it hurt when
you come and broke three chairs on you
and you both did it hurt that hurt that
here's a secret that was actually my
idea I thought it'd be really funny so I
brought that on myself
I'm encumbered I have too much stuff oh
Jesus cuz I have a giant drop the roof
sledgehammer yeah oh that's pretty cool
I gotta say brain keeping all these
things in my backpack
alright you know what I'm going to on
equip I'll just try I don't want to
destroy it somebody just mentioned each
character in this game has like five
different voice act it's not true
destroy I don't want to destroy it Oh
shots fired from Bert 3:11 state of
cliche another zombie game this designer
named Sylvester
shots fired alright fine best zombie
games let's go you first Daisy right no
I like I mean I don't really play zombie
games I'm not a zombie for exampie fan
my favorite zombie game probably dying
like just because it's one of the only
ones I've ever played there we go
alright I'm destroying this sledgehammer
it's too much it's ten pounds I can't
carry that no yeah you didn't even sweat
this swing the swing right on that
wasn't even that good nothing left in
the old alright let's go let's let's
fine let's not find someplace to go here
dude let's just drive I'm gonna yeah
let's just try bro
let's just take through the road all
right which way guys these are always
fun
I really like the Red Dead resent
Redemption 100 that was super fun I had
like Oh which way am I going should I go
this way way where are you the Redwoods
or where is this oops
oh let's see you know we can't look at
the map oh I didn't even consider the
Resident Evil look at the map oh here we
are
oh yeah alright let's head down here
what do you think yeah ah Jesus get up
that first dress we just break this
guy's too subtle we was actually pretty
Oh Lilly sad you guys am I going the
right way
so this to see that the the Ford Fiestas
survived apocalypse
boink oh geez oh geez oh geez still the
most popular car in the United States
there's somebody make sure he's dead
died find the unicorn undead nightmare
no I never did that so the Red Dead
Redemption thing oh it's a horde let's
kill him yeah yeah God was just running
over a state of State Farm
Stephen Harry again there's a State Farm
it's a fun look I like that one that's
more like stative okay okay we're gonna
swear right now we're searching for a
community of survivors you know what I
gotta say one of my favorite movies
zombie movies ever 28 days later state
of YMCA SK rude killing it winner
we haven't heard it yet points go
seedy action Matt Martius are you shy
should I look in here I feel like this
is gonna be there's guys coming out of
here
I'm not strong enough man yeah but
you'll come back good and you can run
them all over that's true this game
scares me a lot just wait till it gets
nighttime any times horrifying
yeah state of bleh crying oh wait new a
new survey point that's good cuz you can
go up on the read the pizza-delivery
trap that's a good idea
wait let me just kill these guys real
quick nurse
you missed my car
whoops oops is there a pizza delivery
boy oh look at all the boat oh no my car
dude I'm dragging something something's
on my get off the thing what am i
dragging like a body or something
oh it's a bumper look at how much blood
is on this Connor that's awesome great
job on dadlabs I like your car get some
bloody look at that it's insane all
right
I've killed a lot of guys let's duel
surveying here Oh see they here they can
hear the they can hear the car it's just
hide in here for a second get drunk can
you get drunk ah good question I think
you can I'm gonna wait a second just a
dog dude hey hey baby
do you hear me yeah
turn around
the problem is now another guy here to
you dude and I'm trapped in here this is
bad it's a bad scene now they're all
coming over here please please no please
no no no yeah turn on the flashlight
that'll help all right run away run away
let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go back outside back outside pizza
delivery truck let's jus come
jus come run around them pizza truck
pizza again we'll see ya oh I got a car
now no you guys are dead
come on come on outside come on outside
you see that mean about like this game
getting kind of scary because you don't
really have like you're not strong in
this game which I really like just keep
driving yeah alright let's just explore
should we just explore so much XP was
left that part I wanna see what do you
got state of boot a well done Scott
speed it that's a state I lived in yeah
oh yeah here's my shirt today and oh god
you know who laughs at this shirt people
have eaten in Chipotle all right let's
see here all right what should I do
should I go dry fast dry fast all right
let's just go drive it any time I'm in a
car in a game I just want to drive as
fast as I do want to see this I would
like to see the survey point that's
gonna help us what's it say it lets you
um well there's a guy closing in on me
where's the survey point here oh right
just chill out at certain points like
you climb up high and then you get to
state of Chipotle just ate of Chipotle
that's a state I'm gonna live in at
about 2:00 p.m. today when I go eat
there yeah what's your favorite everyone
their favorite that what they get at
Chipotle go actually O'Malley has
something let's find this survey point
we got to get a pie and then we could
see what like what things where we can
go like search for stuff alien isolation
is state of eBay state of eBay make some
money reselling stuff where is the state
of play great movie is that a is that
the circuit oh there's a survey point
that's it right there oh they're so
caught up in the chicken king who is
other people yes the survey points that
it was a community oh yeah okay utterly
delicious they serve utters do you think
milk there's a lot of guys here you know
what I'll do here's what I'm gonna do
let's talk the horn and get a bunch of
people out here
oh dude honk the horn get them all
following it and then just slam it in
reverse that's a good idea just stay in
one place insurmountable and then just
like get slowly out of reach
oh here they come here they come get
that first do it again do it again
everybody out
pizza's here pizza one coming at you
from the front hey is it just me but or
you guys when you by yourself and you
order pizzas like sometimes all cuz I'll
order a couple pizzas cuz why make them
come more than once you know yeah yeah
and then when they when when I come to
the door after I pay I'll be like
alright guys pizza's here because I hate
the fact I'm alone in order two pizzas I
deliver a guy think I'm just
oh I do I do I do and I get breadsticks
and sometimes like though chicken
poppers I go I go Pizza breadsticks
wings so that's you know what I don't do
and I'm firmly against dessert pizzas
against it terrible no that's just a
cookie for some reason I'm always more
like excited about cheesy bread pizza
Sears pizza's here
even though cheesy bread with dipping
sauce is just pizza that you put the
sauce on yourself oh no the cars on fire
that's bad yeah I'm gonna need a new car
that's the other thing that's kind of
like there's only a finite amount of
cars in this game so you kind of go to
radio stations good question you know
I'm gonna have to do in a second here is
like just drive far away yeah yeah
I just want to kill as many zombies as I
can wow they're really coming out of the
woodwork here yeah just coming out of
woodwork oh no I don't have a door
anymore that's bad that means that they
could pull me out okay you know what oh
there's a big guy over there to you who
hit him
wait where's the there's a screamer
something Oh in that so there's
different kinds of zombies this game
screamers are ones that attract hordes
and hordes are bad hordes are really
hard to kill by yourself unless you have
a car oh I'm supposed to find this new
community which I'm going to here's what
I'm doing I'm killing a bunch of zombie
and clear out the zombies so I can get
to that survey point right there it's
that little Tower so then I can see what
kind of supplies are over here well
because I before I got entrapped before
all right
they know I'm there there's a screamer I
knew it I knew that scream was done son
no no just goat okay okay well it
doesn't matter cuz you do he's gonna way
he's gonna scream at you yeah well he's
gonna yeah he will it sucks yeah he will
it's up it's it is awful you think I'm
joking it's not Hollow after I get these
the dumpsters there except fun yeah they
actually get a climb very well yeah
better than me hello Gormley marcus
Gormley is that from something like that
youtube video guy right Gormley he sings
that little all right maybe after I find
a community let's switch off and you
play I like the way these towers look
there we go LTC now alright so you know
yeah see so now we could see like what's
around us it's gonna give us get you
talking I want some medicine you know
how your dogs broken Oh what do we got
here oh this is interesting this is cool
yeah cuz you need that likes it's not
like Far Cry where it just automatically
finds all this stuff you actually get to
like look for it yeah because when this
happens in Far Cry like it just tells me
a ton of [ __ ] and I'm like okay great I
don't care about what any of them
exactly but also tell the thing I like
to is like you see zombie hordes yeah
which is cool because that you really
have to just a house this house the
vehicles is good [ __ ]
yeah this game is awesome very deep I
can't recommend that was all this is all
this and that marked on your map now
yeah cool construction site is great so
like part of this game is why I love it
so much is it's kind of like again Grand
Theft Auto it has like that the action
of that with resource management you
have to get like supplies and stuff back
to your back to your people
oh man I'll see some bee horde we don't
that's scary hopefully it won't turn
this way diner there the diner
cheeseburgers milkshakes zombie horde
man hopefully the zombie horde will just
go he's Charlie state of decay the Beth
Beth murasky gave you plates to educate
about oh here let's look in what's down
that family plays The Sims well there's
the see alright I think we should go I'm
just gonna go kill the screamer real
quick anyway Mike like is this similar
to the Screamers from the movie
streamers no no I mean the first rated-r
movie I ever saw whoa
my dad took me to go see Basic Instinct
when I was like 13 yeah it's pretty
hostile he was like just don't tell your
mother
and with all this sex meets like don't
tell your mom my dad took me to see Navy
SEALs whoa there we go
taco chief isn't every building a zombie
popular ah see I told you gah
but I hope you told my mom it was a
cartoon about seals that was I would
watch that and she didn't have the
Internet or anything or bother to look
it up let's go in here look around for
some food real quick so the black dots
are places that there might be something
and they're highlighted when they're not
my favorite highlight effect in a game
why we'll say it helps it night because
things get very dark okay so at night
it's good see I usually just like a
single a single color line oh this is
great
we played outlast right we did play
outlast I'm a gamer know if we play it
outlasted a gamer okay well you know
what then you know what I'm gonna do is
use some of this stuff but the problem
is since I've been killed so much you
see my bar is is real low so I basically
need to at some point need to go back
medicines important you would drop one
of our weapons I mean you're not using
them at all yeah but you can you take
them back to the community you can like
leave them there um you know what we'll
just I think it'll be on our map that
there's medicine here still I thought
you should be you know what you should
be able to do sunsetting days you should
be able to fill a car up with supplies
that would be great you can radio you
can radio for your you're like when
there's a big group of like when there's
a big cache of whatever you can radio
and your people will come and get it and
you see them but sometimes they get
killed doing it there's like a lot of
zombies in the way it's bad man scary
alright as soon as I find these other
survivors we're gonna trade off yeah
oh yeah this a guy okay all right
definitely want to avoid that screamer
all right oh god there's a zombie horde
dude you should go fight this screamer I
want to see what one looks well here's
the thing man that whip no I don't want
to you know I'm gonna go kill this
zombie board real quick
I think it's oh wait what is this it's a
cool octopus vehicle storage hey you can
this is a little thing Oh awesome
see wow this is great think alike well
done Steve decay undead labs
oh that's cool I haven't played lifeline
either so awesome this is great what is
this I will destroy that screamer I'll
make it you know I griefer its mama
alright don't get killed please don't
get killed
it's got octopus graphics on the side of
it so there was a douchebag before don't
fly that guy's dead spray-painted on the
front of this car alright you just
wanted to this is a great whoa sniper
job TV band that guy hey sniper job TV
see you later - trash get out of here
yep no way what are you - where you
belong go back to go back to you alright
alright you just want to go kill the
screamer alright so X so what now don't
you tell me no I'm gonna tell you
because I don't want you to get murdered
alright X X swings be like defends this
I'm gonna get them sprinkler and then
okay and I'll just you know also though
and then this uses whatever is there so
it's medicine so you don't get medicine
so don't use
yeah I mean use right trigger when
you're ready to kill know that that car
is the real state of decay yeah exactly
stay to culture state of no way stay out
of no way great great job driving Wow
amazing
the controls that are pretty they're
little noisy super responsive oh yeah
make that what makes it worse I think
he's over there and all right oh yeah
kill him kill him get the horn
Oh our two backs yeah but I mean right
left right
careful dude careful dragon again these
controls are really laggy yeah I know
but I cut I got I gotta say though I in
adds to the horror of this I know it's
like it's I mean again like it's kind of
like GTA like it's a house that you
Oh
these puns real estate of okay well done
state of Fenway we there we go Boston I
look at all the blood and the octopus
I do love undead labs great job with the
blood car blood on point in this game
it's not a bug it's a feature like me
Michael say oh you killed it
that was the scream oh wait try to kid I
think I don't know if you killed him ago
is it yeah well no no he doesn't have
any arms
is he dead I think yeah he got him in
that you were afraid of that oh dude
just trust me oh it went it calls horns
- you like it stare like it's great in a
car you don't always have a wall done
you don't have a car the sploosh state
of LA tasting face Konica the state of
Subway that's true oh nice alright let's
explore some buildings man let's get
into this let's get into this
neighborhood Oh Oh get out of car deed
that sucks also it's gonna hear your
explore I'll Drive alright I'm a driver
now I like driving you know what's sad
about the octopus car we stash some
stuff in the stove is gonna blow away
state of x-play so guy behind me great
aim is great I love the undead labs is
one of my favorite games of all time why
is there a car yeah what's the story
with the car the octopus 'im alright I'm
gonna hide for a second that's here's
now here's the thing I know you're
making fun of the fact I'm really scared
of this game the sun's going down dude
and then the S is gonna hit the F the
shit's gonna hit the fan and things are
gonna get real scary I even abbreviated
I don't know you're right I don't know I
don't know pardon my letters I took so
many screenshots by the Nescafe what is
that
what am I saying over here for
please be quiet yeah perfect yeah oh
dude nah I'm not happy about this
close-quarter situation oh sweet cool
backpack what's that a JanSport that's
no chance but you're gonna get a
JanSport there I gotta say ah I knew
this is a bad idea coming into this
house I knew it dude flat screen I get a
flat screen oh this is bad I feel very
exposed here I'm happy very unhappy
let's go let's go search it let's go
take it off take it off take it off
give that reproof in the shoving your
open wounds ah he's just hanging out
sorry I noticed your house is killing
him I don't want to build a barricade
there's this horrifying level and the
last one where you had to build
barricades and just they're coming in
and it's just terrible shut that door
thank you know at home sorry zombies I
took so many screenshots by the way of
like me hiding like this and just hordes
coming byes very scary oh man dude when
it get tonight I'm so nervous
you've known it because a pretty big
house nice we need a maid or something
that's gross what do you think I think
it was a party I think was a party uh
yeah food fight and they were having
chocolate pudding or or just bullet with
bullet hole Oh a gun
all right fine let's drop one of the
backpacks yeah we don't need so many
backpacks what are you gonna put in the
backpack can I destroy to destroy us I
don't want to can I can I drop I guess I
have to destroy it uh it's a bar I hate
destroying stuff all right we need that
gun though here's the thing about the
gun man nice it's too loud the guns I
don't play with guns in this game like
to get him uh nope nope not going in
that room who's just smashing its head
on the wall wait look what uh why did I
text her when I was drunk that was so
stupid he's not a zombie
king of Pocky scared of level would
break down without the knives a true
horror of level 99 what you know what
bring'em I haven't been able so far to
do the sneak-up instant kill thing which
I think I'm gonna I would like to so I
just get in there and kill him let's
just do it they're all firebot in there
I don't have any fire bombs bill you do
I do this is not gonna go well no way
this go as well all right
very bad we are told you you told you
was it very well I told you I told you
well you're in a house I told you here
bomb
I guarantee the zombies are on unfazed
you don't even notice throw it anybody
that's pretty insane and they even
notice throw it in the room there yeah I
wonder if you hold it it's RM RB RB RB o
d-pad switch is the thing man that's an
outside toy somebody said that's true
careful careful
Barbie nope get out of there bro Oh same
results although you did hit the zombies
yeah don't shoot don't shoot him it's
gonna be too loud
by the way look they really captured
this game like the long shadows like
this is [ __ ]
that scares me that's horrifying what I
love it's so scary love you too Resident
Evil dude we're having a great day so
far except for the fact that I was on
fire because I tried to throw a gas bomb
inside are you making it very Kade for
no reason that's a good idea
no I just said you can make one if you
want to
it might honestly might help things yeah
what if one of those terrifying
screamers you know your wife I got the
screamer but it's scary Doctor Octopus
yes the sound mechanics and the summer
camps are super important because that's
how you're telling where the zombies is
that's where you go inside for me oh
don't go yeah let's lock him in here
with us great idea yeah
nice do don't the controls have that
little bit of like I can't let go oh
nice
you know what switch do you some
medicine uh on about three yes just for
Pokemon is it worth it yes see it says
yes and and be be be sneaks if you want
to sneak around the house the Screamers
are terrified Thank You Resident Evil
dude I was spoken like a man driving a
giant octopus car oh
stative creep a that's true yeah yeah
those help cuz you you said it and it
throws it it's like a distraction
alright which was the house no no it'll
tell you it'll be an X on it when it's
done well this is what we're doing at
our office so you're helping our
productivity so thank you for that I
would creep I would creep so you're
making noise man see that blue circle
that's the noise or there's no zombies
in here what do you tell you yeah we
thrash them all dude oh my god your
hubris is amazing yeah but I do one more
sweep Steven and actually search around
hey hey crazy hops 31 I mean I see paint
canisters on this show yeah but what are
we gonna use nothing what are you gonna
get you're gonna paint see found nothing
but it took all the paint canisters out
this off so I have a ton of 3dsxl man
but if you're gonna get the 3dsxl get
the new 3ds XL how much time do you
think a modeler spent making all these
clothes Oscar's flat I don't know
can you crouch and see they're pretty
great that's good
cans I love I love just like the trash
everywhere like it's awesome she want to
know her name it's Beth Beth murasky
Steven Smith Jason O'Malley Oh nervous
no don't oh please just run away please
just run away dude BBB
please just run away from this oh yeah I
love this ablution by the way undead
labs great Oh God
please run away just you're almost dead
please run away undead labs great job by
the way look we all we all were saying
before you guys logged in how the skin
coming off the zombies head and he
killed his awesome alright rlb sprints
can't can't get it can't get in it it's
too rusty
you didn't even fully search the house
we haven't found anything within every
room in that house and clear what
there's an upstate look so there's no
don't go back in the house you're gonna
lead them back in the house yeah I'm
gonna get trapped you're gonna get
traffic already you're gonna get you're
gonna get trapped there's already
zombies in here get out of this house
just go out get out of the house please
get out of the house
Oh where's this HP bar what I move the
camp
oh yeah can you do you want to me a
flavor and can you scoot it over to the
right oh yeah the pnp just here just
yeah yeah cuz we can't see they can see
them don't there's another zombie right
next to you I'm realizing not if there's
a zombie apocalypse not to be in Stevens
group just Majora's Mask got 3ds is
awesome oh yeah also super smash is
great and it's you know blade chronicles
awesome game is rad gimme I am a
backseat gamer this is true bleep oh
dude what are you doing I'm trying to
get more zombies oh I see if you're
trying to attack say I'm a backseat
gamer this is true
yeah yes although is all how about some
fire scarecrow get out of here bro oh
you're just I take it back man lb+ why
chose him on the ground also well done
dude
geom because it's just bothering my
sense of whatever I need to go search
the Reza's house did we source it this
is it I thought it's supposed to have an
X I guess not fair enough all right oh
man look at that Sun nervous I'm real
nervous about it going down all right
where should i search what do you guys
which i search or should i go that's a
horde that's a zombie horde see this is
what I'm talking about how freaky is
this this is scary dude like those guys
would kill me don't don't look over here
Steven I don't want to read this out of
your hair
oh let's rush no no no no nope nope nope
not did you see me just thrash a million
zombies you thrashed five zombies this
is like 13 yeah I'll kill every single
zombie no problem yeah let's just that's
scary let's just creep away this is why
this game is good all right go search
we're gonna go search we're gonna find
another house should I go home and
switch out characters we dead in two
years lol Zelda be the last real game
that's what they said about we but it
was the most successful of all the
systems there's a guy over there uh well
should we go back to our home kill you
all the zombies is a bad plan Land y
times I agree alright let's uh let's go
here this is where we're gonna go before
let's go here oh wait are we close to
you know what I think we're closer to
this let's go over here we're gonna try
to find another community here
man I want a million more Molotov
cocktails okay well I want a million
dollars so we can't get move on looks
like a pretty sunset tonight no way I'm
gonna try and you did let's try this
sneaky fella zombies I try to sneak then
too far away get them now see that
didn't work
yeah we know that all those buttons do
is whisper to this I think I wasn't
closing I'm gonna switch on my weapon
real quick some little mice or something
it's an ax that I know but I'm just
saying if I want to be able to swing I'm
more of a fast swinger I want to be able
to swim fast
all right oh yeah so now you can see oh
whoops
[Music]
have we ever played Metro two zero three
three nope Tony its state of decay see
dude not starting it dark and I'm
starting at real creeps so what happens
when it's dark you just can't see
anything
it's like activate like and I think it's
dying light or no I think there's like
more hordes about and I'm not sure if
they get more powerful but I see the
Horde he's way over there gonna get
yourself a whip yeah man there's a lot
of zombies around here
all right let's what run into the Horde
no hold on one second I just want to
make it to this house real quick you
know all right so there's a guy over
there too you could sneak by this guy
[Music]
yeah no kidding you have to play Metro
2033 or soccer also not a fan of the
more glowing eyes in this game
really come on let's go let's go that's
a great idea ever like forest fire
oh man there's a lot of zombies around
here [ __ ] do it this isn't this isn't
going well you know what's good about
the red eyes you'll be able to see them
in the dark
good point that's wrong let's run the
turn shite the Horde just on oh yeah
hungry oh my god the hordes right here
can i oh oh god they're allergic let's
get high no I'm good I'm good
in tennis [ __ ] whoa
tell where's the light oh my god we
never made it to me we killed 35 all
right let's try it let's try again that
was my fault
damn start a new jeans oh there we go
let's be Trevor Jacob J greater my
neighbor from when I was a kid jr. crazy
all your friends are dead is this
[Laughter]
Christo 22 stated perfect we could put a
back together
alright alright you gotta kill these two
guys up top I'm Jesus really let's just
go find survivors immediately yeah oh
that's a great shot I will say undead
labs I don't want to I mean this might
be a fun dlc but an easter egg being
able to turn on benny hill music it
looks burnt out
go for it though there's a guy behind
you you know i eat some what RT do eat
some i mean ii RB RB there you go that
music is copyrighted you're right
but you can do a little you can do a
little while Ripa oh look at this I say
I significant theme all the time while
making this game there you go behind the
scenes there you go little web exclusive
you guys I did left sang Benny music
you can't tell me especially the way
Stephen and I drive or more the way I
Drive that you can't just hear Benny
Hill music the entire time hit they hit
they hit this button to see our map also
the thing you happened also the game
just so you guys know the game goes on
while the map is on this is where you
smoking weed or something this is how I
Drive I got down everything I see
there was one miss I hate bureaucrats
take that government I don't know if
we're still in Trumbull Valley oh we are
still in trouble Valley there's this
awesome plane crash in the middle of
like a cornfield I wonder if it could
find it do this places Manson I know
it's awesome
wait wait wait hit the map let's see we
can find the plane crash it's awesome
looking this one it's written really
scary like it way our our stick out our
stick out I think it's yeah I think it's
like right I think it's no no down down
down I think it's like that it's like up
there it's like right here yeah okay
because that seems like yeah a good
place to go let me just take a right is
there Illuminati spam you can be
banhammer it's all right well buff Ethel
put down the ban hammer Oh God do it
yeah get down to that swampy swampy oh
that's a blogger dude no no no to stay
away from he's gonna blow up he's gonna
blow up shoot him from afar shoot him
from afar that's bad you wanna get away
from thing it's bad it's really bad try
to hit him with the car I guess it's
like something from calories it's gross
yeah there you go just filled with a
fart is that a fart since huh now you've
got uh see you're going down he hits you
so you're going down get out of the car
Oh likes dying
get away from that oh you're dead you're
dead hole dead oh we're dead you're dead
I can't believe he died twice I can't
believe we're about to die
no you crouching the bushes you can hide
oh Jesus I ain't afraid of no ghosts
there that goes there zombies get out of
there get out of there get out of there
just go and hide in the book please play
you've little faith man I got it the
guy's like stumbling away octopus party
help lb lb y d lb y lb y I'm on the
ground
Oh Kidder oh yeah awesome that was
awesome now you can always crouch in any
hiding a bush and they won't see you you
can do that but I think it's not like
you're being like chased immediately
oh also I forgot about we have the timer
- so if that happens again you could
throw a time all the time that's right
Resident Evil dude that's got the
banhammer which honestly is the most
powerful weapon at the time the
banhammer the y3 speeches oh I just
heard I just heard that like in Lisa
Simpson's voice oh this is a good idea
wow that was great though props too by
the way I do I have to say like it is Oh
God oh no oh no dude no you're trouble I
like how you fall out of the car that's
kind of over
ooh that'll be what honest Oh God run
dude run run away this game so scary Oh
God
oh dude get up get up
oh please get up Jacob run dude just run
away you can hide in those weeds bee bee
bee bee all right just state your beat
be hold be just stay there
there you go then won't be able to see
you can't go for a swim I don't know if
you swim this game you try yeah I mean
they're gonna see you in the water
there's a guy chasing you so this is
whatever up the ration get it there's
two you saw your medicine really because
I'm almost exactly the aggressive
lanolin monkey says alright look there's
a swamp zombie I you know what I would
do is not let's go ask where you keep
all the frog you can't kill all the
zombies in this game you just can't do
it
I beg to differ I've killed every zombie
up until the one that you don't kill I
do like that the bugs are cool what a
mosquito any kind of particles in a game
make the game better I agree totally
good how do i reck'n yeah
swamps obvious if he said swampy it's a
swampy well played
oh here's where you keep the frogs huh
there's no frogs that's good you know
what we might be able to get some some
petrol bombs from this
oh yeah be dodges be duck we can always
dodge thank you I wish forget about
dodging in games there you go take it
off
so well if you want to hold that you
know you might want to call people to
come get that which it should be why but
it's not well because well because we
haven't found anybody else right so yeah
so so no no so hold X and it'll make it
into smaller it'll make it into smaller
things that you can that's not happening
to hold X you're holding it there you
guys see now you can take it I used to
uh oh here you go it's your favorite
thing never heard Steve Annette happy
nice get it yeah oh great sound too by
the way yeah dude look I like efforts oh
the death rattle go on petrol bombs
ready I have six oh man it's Christmas
time it's gonna be fire Christmas I've
never gotten yeah you guys like Jeff
Bridges no don't do it
see now they get to run at me from a
fire like mocha yeah look like a Nick
Cage amazing I gotta say from I never
really thought of a mic stand is a great
zombie weapon but those things are
pretty heavy yeah you get a good
leverage like it's great look at the
waterfall oh it's pretty
you know what prettying up some fire you
know what I love this use waterfall by
firelight
oh yeah well done urn Splash Damage get
it Splash Damage he really doesn't
there's no cat what is his Legend of
Zelda
what do you cut you like behind on a
forest temple yeah behind the waterfall
you actually go into like a crazy
fantasy world I'm like Final Fantasy's
and like laser swords it just turns
impose insanely like Alps and stuff did
you see that Kanye quest thing no that's
my paycheck right there well done grind
keys to door well done also the mud then
walk it through the mud look at that
that's great I gotta say this is a big
step up from the Xbox 360 version
graphically and I think scope wise like
even like the shine on his leather
jacket like it looks really cool here
always I gotta say it kind of bummed me
out
Oh playing the first state of decay it
was really awesome but oh god I kind of
bummed me up because it was like you
could tell what they were trying to do
but like it just was one of those things
were I'm sure they just resources that's
great great idea yep oh dude that's bad
oh god oh but good idea there you go
that was good
great job no no no no okay are you sure
in the letters truce but it it bummed me
out a little bit because I was like so
many games getting made that I'm not a
fan of are you sure you don't have any
medicine yeah
so many games that get made you know or
just like to have a ton of money if I
don't really aren't really you know and
you could tell like undead labs that
they're trying to make something great
amazing and they it was just it like the
fun was still there but I was like oh
man like what if this was on you know
what if they actually had some crazy
resources and then would they actually
did so like Barry
they rereleased they realist this game
and this I feel like is it's so great
because it's like such a great world and
like the thing is like again like very
few games I've gotten in my head the way
that said oh Jesus Christ oh dude -
please remember art remember lby
powerhouse dude but very few games have
ever gotten in my head like haunted me
the way to state of decay haunts me
horrifying Oh suits in that farm that's
like when I couldn't save my dad when he
fell off that bridge yeah the same thing
yeah but worse yeah cuz it affected me
yeah okay exactly I don't care about
your dad fine yeah well I'm not I'm
haunted by the case so you know
different strokes
there's nothing in there it's got an X
on it no insulation what if it gets cold
at night ah there's something running
towards you it's a little fast you can
do it bridges bridges junior it was just
a regular guy hey Fred just dead let's
try to find it don't waste all the
bullets this game is about resource
management what are you doing
all right that's it Nadel the worst
that's horrifying
yeah thank you better make these count
better make these count and and also
just know please at least shoot a zombie
with it you can get a headshot that's if
you duck that's you know then you're
dead you're dead and I want it I am at I
want to see you die you're playing so
dumb I want yep get it kill him get him
you're dead
dead man dead man well you do pretty
good so far
yeah I gotta say you know what you're
pretty tenacious I live to kill Jacob
always didn't have a bit of a death wish
that's true
Jacob wants to die he's praying for
death yes I do love that's what I love
about sandbox games too it's like yeah
see that guy way over there let's go
over there oh dude we were gonna see the
plane crash you know what after you die
which will be in about 30 seconds we're
gonna check out the plane crash I'm
gonna find hella pills hella pills
hashtag hella pills zombie hunter mode
activated she sneaked up on him known as
she could sneak up perhaps we'll take
you in you know what I hope they don't
take Jacob in he's a psychopath he
doesn't deserve to be isn't this cool
freaking house probably has some
ibuprofen or acetaminophen yeah I like
how all the medicine in this game is
just whatever my pediatrician
yeah you have a pediatrician oh when I
was a kid Stevens got a bunch of kids
that's what I call it sneak attack lanky
mugger oh dude it's nerdy sneak up on
him and kill him no please don't
what are you doing don't eyes open that
would blow up I can't remember if those
below or not
ooh that's a nice truck pop up in a web
game that we know look they're having a
deck party yeah hey you want to come to
our party see dude this job see if you
can get to that I wanna see if you can
get to the see all that detour nothing
had nothing bad happened except you're
almost dead you can't wear your maximum
vitality is low because you've been
attacked so many times you wasted a ton
of bullets you have no medicine oh yeah
you know what wait I could show you
where the plane crash is go keep going
straight and then take are right it's
like behind these mountains it it is
cool you do want to see it it's pretty
odd no no you're fine keep going
you're gonna reach a thing I just want
to get some pills yeah there might be
pills in the plane in the plane I think
had although we continued my other game
oh yeah I did horde style
alright so wait now go try to go
straight can you like go around there
there yeah and then and then I think
it's it's gonna be like yeah you keep
going it's gonna be like on a right
there's gonna be a road take a right
there's an awesome mission by the way
where yeah here it is take a right take
a right take a right there's an awesome
mission where there's like like I think
it happens like right here where all
these zombies are coming in yeah oh here
we go
I think it's over here so I think it's
over here somewhere oh there it is look
at the plane how can I and then the
shittiest wouldn't wouldn't offensive oh
here we go is that dude isn't this sweet
and you can search the plane you know
it's sweet woo cube Benny Hill music and
I hope you're comfortable it never gets
old
dude check out that plane look at these
three kids what are you guys smoking
weed on the dudes get see it see if you
can search the plane I just gotta you
know clear the area sandy shores
because destructible geometry is really
expensive haha I believe it that'll be
in the next Delvian state of decay too
boom I love it when that I do love when
they drag it's really fun
whoo there's the others I guess I must
say I do I do kind of like the fact that
I mean just you know destruction
geometry being expensive or not it adds
to the horror when you can't when you
have to get out of your car or like your
trash it's like it's I like the fact you
can't get through the fence because it's
like sometimes you know you're just like
no life left or there oh dude screamer
kill him I want you to see one of these
big boomers wears this they don't screw
so many ARMs
oh sweet oh that's cool that's some boys
oh yeah back into a vaca noon yeah our
rear needs a nice cut a new coat of
paint what what Pantone color is so
beautiful
oh there is that see if you can kill
this didn't kill a screamer I know where
he's at I think he was on the other side
of the field
hey guys hop on hop on guys let's go
scrape off the side scrape them off the
side remember if on the other side
sometimes they'll pull you out of the
car which is fine just scrape off this
back yeah I got this plane what do you
think zombies got on the plane plane
zombies oh maybe you can't go inside wow
there were supply I think before they
it's like supplies scattered around it I
might be lying dead island you know I
got to say uh one game I actually oh
yeah see I think over there who climb on
the plane Dead Island what was the game
in the mall that came really upset me Oh
rising dead rising was good but you had
to eat too often and the save points in
the bat there weren't enough bathrooms
to save your game which was annoying Oh
see that guy right there he's trying to
sneak up on me yeah nice bullets thank
goodness somebody who shoots at the sky
oh god please shoot him shoot him shoot
him shoot it but a little rock and roll
to the head to the head ooh nice said
can we please find some survivors now
okay oh good I've shown you the plane oh
here you can't go inside the plane there
we go headshot him
don't don't shoot the sky just shoot it
one zombie just for me Oh Dead Rising 3
is good it's on the Xbox one oh thanks
old crotchety I'll have to check that
out I think Halloween this year we're
gonna do a whole big we'll do a special
zombie run yeah dad will do a special
event it's a myth
ya know what if that was the all the
cabin there's only four seats in this
play it's all fuel this plane is
terribly design Civ ok let's first first
class this car seems like it's drivable
right sure let's get inside
yo yeah don't hit him with the car
because he'll kill you wait where is he
I was just because there is a thing
there are big guys and you can hit them
with your car it'll destroy your car
it's awesome and they're called boomers
okay you know what hit hit the hit the
the map to see let's put a let's put a
point let's put a point how are you
doing oh yeah yeah yeah yeah oh this is
bad dude the car starts flaming I don't
know if there's another car around here
he says he passed two cars a little
faith I don't know I don't know don't
look like they work uh-huh no smartass
hey there might be something to farm us
Oh jogger nuts they're called thank you
during a tank jaggernots are not fun
although they are killable they're just
extremely not fun
none of these are gonna work oh yeah
we're going back to now this is where
we're going back to before our thing
before if you want to go to the right
this is don't driver it's this day if
you want to sneak by that you can go
back to where we were before but I think
you should go oh boy oh boy
boomers are from left for dead that's
right oh dude there you go that's where
our car kinda looks now like Eddie Van
Halen's guitar all right so this is like
so this is like kind of where our home
base is you know what maybe just go to
the home base that the blue building I
think if we're still there I don't know
because I continued my game from before
but it doesn't look like I need the
fortification over there so might not
that might not be our home base RB r lb
lb runs lb Sprint's oh yeah dude nope
not our home base oh oh yeah this is a
this is a great home site though I was
killing them Here I am oh sure yeah just
leave me left for dead great uh doing
good not the blue building I think I did
pretty good
you did well I'm gonna go try to find a
community here's the problem
oh there's a horde back there I'm gonna
take this little yellow car yeah yeah
yeah I'm gonna go to the green oh sorry
guys I wasn't playing the game very
productively sorry let's go let's go Oh
a new thing too that's in this Xbox one
edition which is nice and it's freaky
just scrape them off the side is the
cars don't start immediately which is a
little story yeah so it's like you do
have that horrifying and I wonder if
there are cars that don't start which
would be awesome if you actually can't
start a car
should be just because 99 times out of
100 I'm just praying like just I use the
car to get out oh we're going to the
city you made it the city right yeah
yeah the big city
the big city see that city's actually
kind of scary because there's a lot of
dead ends I could play this game for
days I know man this day this game is
insane it gets in your head like oh hey
that chiapas alright hold on one sec let
me just I need let's just go to the
community see here's like the downtown
it's awesome and you can search all
these buildings by the way oh you see
that
city man hate the city city's the worst
really the worst it's so scary go there
right now in this we're in the city this
is the city well it's one of the cities
there's another hole there's all like
fairgrounds it's there's a hole oh
there's a town sorry there is a city
though there's a zombie horde sorry car
I'll watch this oh this is what I like
to do sometimes you just funnel them in
so they got a bus hey guys
and it's also scary level or you gotta
clean out of school that's for a fine
okay all right so the park will car here
so I don't take them all where the Alamo
happened yeah this is actually where the
real Alamo happened hey there's a person
and they turn it into a rust man in
there yeah oh that's this is part of the
game huh this is the whole game there we
go
here's your boy hey buddy hey guys me
Jake Ritter hey George Gilchrist lead
singer of what huh
what are you what hey man I'm a nice guy
kill these people uh yeah but we don't
wanna kill them dude you can know like I
can I can get my mic stand out and smash
their heads no that's a good thing Q
probably good even good people if you
want you can crash with us let's join
them yeah join the community guys
awesome by the way
Bianca and George that's a terrible
place to set up an outpost in the middle
of a city or idiot
sorry started especially in a place of
enormous windows yes Norma's covered
unprotected windows is the dumbest thing
ever should I make can I bring their
supplies dude oh yeah you know you know
and I'm gonna give some supplies maybe I
should equip this with my backpack
situation now I think it's the same bag
chenla is good to have you knew all
right morale all right so this is C this
is this stuff so we're gonna look for
some food to bring back here with no
medicine so I'm gonna add some medicine
to the I don't have any medicine
language please Jeremiah I don't really
use guns that much but whatever this all
looks good all right
oh wait I was gonna put the backpack in
here
whoops you go on the roof of this
building Sears what they have
take them all tops you'll be needing
those
I will er you will I'm gonna take some
snacks too got some I don't really use
these some of the stash this all right
let's go actually know what maybe I
should switch us somebody else look this
guy rest that's one of them that's one
of the good thing oh this is Lily she's
the one who talks to us oh wait she's
our brother I mean our sister that's our
brother yeah it's our no it's our sister
you can do a come with me never mind
gossip loves books so long I'm gonna try
to be somebody else to get my stats up
that's the thing too in this game it's
important to play all different guys
because come with me and watch my back I
guess I just got to be myself now you
can change the other people it said like
a couple characteristics about each
character when their name popped up and
that guy's was coward and engineer I
think I wanna play as the cop all the
time wait explore the exterior my god
come only shirt at walk fest 2013 yeah I
was there it was awesome it's just like
Lilith Fair but they all sing songs
about guacamole no I got it I think I
might have been scream calm what's the
screen side screened that car having any
organ or bone structure they're just
filled with blood it's awesome
it's just blood let's go in the grocery
store check it out that's you think I
need cheetahs cool mid-century rock
pattern what is the neighbor said
there's nothing wow this is depressing
okay we're gonna help our neighbors
we're gonna help somebody how quick when
we're gonna help
I know it sounds ridiculous how quick do
you think something like this will
happen once it hits are you kidding me
have you seen like when they release a
new Tamagotchi or anything if this is
how it is normally I guess you're right
I remember last time the new Tamagotchi
came out and people were killing when
you're 8 yeah let's do it
yes I love that smash your smasher is
alright
[Music]
hopefully that guy right there won't see
me oh I want to how do I search this
thanks Kenji Oh 586 thank you oh no wait
I'll radio home see now we can do it
yeah cuz it's right across the way there
call for scavengers boom I need to do
some housecleaning establish an outpost
this is a great outpost dude no it's not
oh yeah it is I'm just gonna kill this
guy real good alright here we go
so what is it RB and why
I love that walk around here quickly get
that ghost
it's not a ghost I want I want us to
live long enough to see night because
you should see it because it's
horrifying it's a just a dark version of
the game dude it's it's awesome I mean
it is the fruits and vegetables were
taken all the crap I organic oh yeah so
there's nothing more satisfying wait
look at those characters on those
posters somebody drew those appreciate
them play I'm going to hold on somebody
spend whoo
oh this is Blaine's grocery I love
Lansbury I'm here they say branded the
grocery and gay Blaine and whole that's
apparently heaven
it's full of cheapskates because your
jeans will save you whole dollars I love
it Blaine's grocery farm-fresh that's
the Blaine's promise to you at planes we
only use the freshest local vendors
they're your friends your neighbors
guys that's names oh yeah that's true
though there's a buy your produce at
Blaine's they're helping out a friend
not one bit facetious nope
not how I would do it but okay I love it
apparently in heaven they're cheapskates
yeah we send you whole dollars oh wait
there's some more to these posters I
love it
this is great it kind of reminds me a
little bit of like furniture like a
Bioshock
hey y'all welcome to the Blaine's home
gross you'll love it here we promise
quality local produce they're really
about local produce which was great
Steve local meats distinct local meats
yeah side and you'll sell the difference
especially if you're a zombie apocalypse
you look at this guy would it be funny
if that guy we're just walking around
hahaha and he looks just like that this
time you have to kill Blaine yeah that's
like the last level
just throws like old zombie horde head
he told Tom all right yum-yum please
like a locally grown Wow
there we go yeah uh you know what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna save my new home
from the zombie horde really quickly
cold soft
where be that zombie horde with a
holiday where the Horde on
Miami booth there we go just wait for
these I'm just gonna kill these guys
quickly come on fellas I don't have all
day I got a sword to destroy part wait
somebody's saying we can you say the
thing that somebody said about parking
around home babe really that why cuz
then that'll stop Oh cuz they won't be
able to get over this things can zombies
climb over bless you I prefer traps come
on dudes scrape you off the side Oh dad
pick on the side oh oh no he pulled me
out no come on firebombing oh yes
perfect
this is like what I wanted Dead Rising
yeah exactly
alright I think it's oh let me just kill
this screamer you know what no let him
speak
see this is why the Screamers scary you
can see now the Horde is headed our way
we can you let them all tear you apart
yeah that's a good idea
he doesn't have a dick I'm gonna go kill
this zombie horde by hand show you how
it's done
come on
[Applause]
feel the power rock take some medicine
press our Z aim at our beat get out of
here I'm doing kill yeah I think you
successfully destroyed did I kill it
yeah oh one last look straggler alright
I was tight that was actually pretty
great Wow I can't destroy a horde bye
guys guys I learned something today you
to frame I'm to a friend playing this
game too afraid gotta go in balls get
balls deep
alright alright alright
it goes against everything he's so
sleepy
alright let's see it lets see it
[Applause]
oh my god well that'll do it for this
team Koko Monday melee sorry Jacob
Ritter we had to sacrifice you at the
end there thank you all for joining us
Beth brown-skinned - chattering Steven
Smith Jason O'Malley Thank You undead
lab guys oh yeah Thank You undead lab
guys for oh can you get rid of the
graphic is other thing Thank You undead
lab guys for making such an awesome game
go get state of decay your one survival
edition it's awesome and game I'm gonna
be playing a lot in my spare time now
it's time to go do a show and I'm gonna
go take this mic stand and do something
bad with it thank you for joining us see
you guys next week but
you